-I have to get into a lot
of things, but first,
I want to congratulate you on
recently getting engaged.
-Oh, thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy for you.
-Also, knocked it out
of the park, just saying.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah. No, I scored.
-It's the best thing
in the world.
I can't even tell you.
Now you have a buddy who kind of
has to do things with you.
-I know, and we have to, like,
help each other out
with stuff, too.
-Yeah, it's a whole thing now.
-You got to do the stuff
I don't want to do, man.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the way it works.
It's a relationship, exactly.
-Yeah.
-I love -- You know, every time
you come on the show
and your name comes up,
everyone always says,
"Man, she's the coolest."
And I -- Really.
You have a great reputation.
And I just want you to know that
we love you here.
-Dude, I love that.
-Yeah, do you feel like
you're cool?
[ Laughter ]
-Um, well, it's freezing
in here.
-Yeah, yeah, I'm talking about
temperature-wise, yeah, yeah.
But were you always
the cool kid in school?
-Oh, man, no, I was
so inside out.
Are you kidding?
-Oh, really?
-It's taken years to get to
this conversational point.
-Yeah.
Just like in and just shy?
-Yeah, totally shy, and also,
like, you think about
the cool kids in school,
usually, it's either like --
now, it's synonymous with nice
now that you're -- as adults.
But as a kid, cool is,
like, usually, like, bullies.
I only ever had
one bully experience.
I was, like, mean to someone
once, and from then on, was
like, "Absolutely never again."
I threw nachos in someone's face
because they were mean to me
in kindergarten.
-You threw --
-And it had been
years and years, and then,
straight after that, I was,
like, forever changed.
-Really?
-I saw this girl's face change
and I was like,
"Absolutely not."
That's not -- Yeah. No.
-Wow.
Because she was bullying you
or why?
-She took my best friend
in kindergarten
and I was like,
"Honestly, who are you?"
-Yeah, and "Dude, I'm about
to flip this plate of nachos."
-It was so impulsive.
It came from a deep-seated
resentment in me.
It was a physical reaction.
She walked by and I was like,
"Ooh, that girl,"
and just went like that.
-Yeah.
-"Who do you think you are?
Is that funny to you?"
I wasn't -- I didn't think
it was funny.
-So it changed your life.
-Yeah, I'm starting to sweat.
And it's not hot -- I mean,
it's not cold in here anymore.
[ Laughter ]
I'm burning alive.
-You came on as cool
and now you're warm.
This is so interesting.
I'm happy that you got over
that, yeah.
But then, your parents
are in the business.
And so, did they get you
into this gig?
Or do you remember this girl?
She was in --
-This poor child.
-She was in the "Flintstones"
live-action movie.
[ Audience aws ]
How cute are you?
-Wow.
-Do you remember this?
-I do.
-"Flintstones Viva Rock Vegas."
-Yeah.
-It was your first acting role.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
And how did that come about?
Were you just like --
Were you nervous?
-I nailed it on the first take.
At the time, it was
a serious point of pride.
I was the ring toss girl,
so I had to get this, like,
massive flint stone ring
around a Neanderthal.
And my mom was
the script supervisor,
and I was kicking it around set
and just never wanted to leave.
And so they were like,
"Give her a job."
And there I -- There's my start.
-We actually have the clip here.
This is the back of
Kristen Stewart's head
making its very brief
big-screen debut
in "The Flintstones
in Viva Rock Vegas."
-Can't wait.
-Come on.
-Yay!
-[ Laughs ]
Dude, that was it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, come on, that's the best!
-Also, like, right afterwards --
I know, I go...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's cool.
-I guess you nailed it.
Yeah, I don't know, man.
Oh, my God.
That is a great first clip.
I love that.
And here we are 21 years later,
I think or 20 years later,
playing Princess Diana.
Amazing job, by the way.
Everybody, the whole --
the director, everyone,
did a great job.
But you mastered the accent
and everything.
You know, and I love
seeing people
that are great at what they do.
But watching you act, I just --
I got lost.
I didn't -- I just thought it
was Diana watching for a while.
I'm like,
"This is so fascinating."
Tough to do the accent, is it?
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's, like, so muscular.
It's exhausting.
You have to like --
When I speak, I feel like
I don't open my mouth
and I feel like this,
like, croaked fr--
Words come out of her mouth
like bubbles.
And I'm like bricks
to the floor.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, right?
I mumble all the time as well.
But I mean, it's just --
it was -- anyways.
You get the call
to play Princess Diana,
and what's your first thought?
You go, "Challenging?"
-"Dude, are you sure?"
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, right?
-Yeah.
-But why do you --
It feels like, to me,
you put yourself
in these positions sometimes.
Like, I would say "Twilight"
was a big deal because...
[ Woman giggles ]
...you came --
That book was massive.
-Giggles.
-Yeah, people --
[ Laughter ]
You were like, "Dude, I don't
want to mess this up.
This is -- a lot of people --
These are serious books, man.
I can't mess this up."
-Yeah.
-And you didn't.
You hit a home run.
You knocked it out of the park.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then you get this,
and it's another pressure thing
and you go, "Ooh, I could easily
just not take these roles."
-Yeah.
-And you can just skate on by,
and go, "Yeah, yeah."
But it's a challenge.
I love that you took it.
-Yeah.
Gosh, I mean, like, you know,
I've been doing this
for a minute, so there's
really no way to --
there's no reason to keep going
unless you're going to try and,
you know, push the envelope,
and...
Also, like, if you cancel out
all of that noise, she's so...
She's so sparkly
and she's, like, so completely
complicated and difficult
to understand.
And we lost this person
too early.
And so I think that we're always
kind of -- we're never going to
have the information
that we want to have.
-No.
-So I was like,
"Just embed yourself in your own
desires and curiosities
and try and sort of not think
about other people's."
But I will say that the weight
of that matters.
Her connection to people
matters. That's who she was.
Like, the reason we're telling
this story still
is because she just, like...
-Yeah.
-She reached out and touched
people in a way that
nobody ever really has,
especially in that environment.
So, yeah.
-I want to show --
You did a fantastic job.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kristen Stewart
in "Spencer."
Take a look.
-Mummy, why do we have to open
our presents on Christmas Eve?
Why not Christmas Day
like everybody else?
-You know at school,
you do tenses?
-Yeah.
-It's past, the present, future.
-Right.
-Well, here, there is
only one tense.
There is no future.
The past and the present
are the same thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's getting
a little Oscar buzz,
and it should, for good reason.
Kristen Stewart, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Spencer" is in theaters
nationwide on Friday.